what's up guys welcome back to this
week's update on the bitcoin market
there's been a little relief in the
market and we're gonna break down
exactly what's happening don't forget
that these weekly updates are brought to
you by ftx click on the link in the
description to learn more let's jump in
and see what happened in the past week
first if we take a look bitcoin now
trading just below 24 000
then if we take a look at the bitcoin
network itself we can see that bitcoin's
market cap about 450 billion dollars we
have the inflation rate at 1.76 percent
much lower than the 8.5 percent in the
u.s dollar system
ninety percent of bitcoin has been
issued into the circulating supply and
the real exchange volume in the last 24
hours up significantly now over 26
billion dollars we know that miners in
the last 24 hours have been paid 21.8
million dollars and gbtc is at a
discount of 24.5
then bitcoin still about 65 below its
all-time high of 69 000 back from
november of 2021. if we take a look at
bitcoin versus gold in the s p 500
bitcoin is down nearly 50
over the last year but in a two to ten
year time period bitcoin absolutely
destroying the performance of both gold
and the s p
then we can take a look at bitcoin's
price closing history 23 800
bitcoin is only traded above this level
for 533 days of its lifetime which means
that on 89 of bitcoin's life if you
bought the asset and held till today you
would be in profit
next up we can take a look at bitcoin
versus gold s p 500 nasdaq and tlt we
see that the compound annual growth rate
of bitcoin at 112 over the last 10 years
is drastically higher than anything else
and then of course if we take a look at
the five-year sharp ratio coming in just
below one that means if you took the
asset you put it into a portfolio of
non-correlated assets bitcoin would have
a positive impact well the network stats
are encouraging this week we're gonna do
something a little bit different there
are two main events that have occurred
that i think are important to call out
the first is that the macro environment
is in a very interesting place this past
week we got the inflation reading and it
came in at eight point five percent
that's down from the prior month of nine
point one percent but remember that
headline cpi number that is simply the
year over year change what we saw in a
month-to-month basis was we were flat
that's good news that inflation wasn't
accelerating but it still is not good
news that inflation is not necessarily
coming down we are getting into a base
effect because last year in june july
and through the end of 2021 inflation
went very high it was between five and
seven percent so now as we see readings
in the 8.5 range this is compounded year
after year of very high inflation that
does not spell any sort of good news for
the american consumer not only are we
getting a macro situation that continues
to be perplexing but also we saw a very
huge piece of news coming from wall
street blackrock the world's largest
asset manager they last week announced
that they were going to come in and do a
partnership with coinbase publicly
traded large u.s brand but now blackrock
taking it a step further and they have
announced that they have a private trust
that's been set up to allow their
institutional clients to begin to buy
bitcoin what's interesting about this is
that blackrock has trillions of dollars
under management and they have trillions
of dollars in etfs and if they're
continuing to see demand from their
institutional clients for bitcoin my
guess is that we're about to watch
blackrock launch the private trust get
their institutional clients exposure to
bitcoin they eventually will take that
private trust they'll put it into the
public market similar to grayscale's
gbtc and then blackrock is going to
lobby the sec to approve the bitcoin
trust being converted to an etf this is
exactly what greyscale's been trying to
do but now we have a competition we have
blackrock the world's largest asset
manager in the traditional world going
up against grayscale the world's largest
asset manager in the new digital system
that is a script that is written for a
movie as we continue to look at the
bitcoin market it seems that the market
is determining there's a higher and
higher probability that we probably saw
the bottom somewhere in that 17 000
range that doesn't guarantee that that's
what happened but the market seems to be
pricing in a lot more optimism than they
were just a few weeks ago bitcoin
trading between 22 000 and 25 000 ends
up being pretty healthy if we continue
to go sideways here there seems to be on
chain metrics that suggest that many
people just continue to dollar cost
average into the digital currency
ultimately what will determine bitcoin's
direction up or down over the coming
weeks is going to be the federal reserve
if the fed continues to tighten
financial conditions that will put a lot
of pressure on many investors and it
will push the us economy further into a
recession but if the fed simply pauses
all of that tightening or if they end up
pivoting before the end of the year
including before the midterm elections
then that would be a bullish signal and
all assets including stocks and bitcoin
are likely to recover as we continue to
push towards the end of the year and
into those midterm elections it's
important that you watch the federal
reserve the fed is in control it's all
one big trade and as the saying goes
don't fight the fed bitcoin continues to
hold up decently well in the last few
weeks given the macro drawdown of 70
but the question will become as we go
deeper and deeper into a recession this
is bitcoin's first recession how will it
handle all the pressure so far it's been
fascinating to watch something tells me
it will only get more interesting i hope
that you are enjoying these weekly
updates remember they are brought to you
by ftx if you'd like to buy bitcoin you
can go to ftx and get cheaper fees than
most of their competitors sometimes as
much as 85 cheaper than those
competitors also they've introduced
digital stock trading where you can go
buy various stocks with no transaction
fees and no payment for order flow so
you get better pricing ftx continues to
innovate in financial markets and i'm
proud that they sponsor these weekly
updates if you want to support them go
click on the link in the description and
open up an ftx account today all right
that's it for this week i will see you
all next saturday